week 12 most important matchups chris
i am asking you the question here it is
the lions have
37 wins on thanksgiving and the cowboys
have
31. who has the third
most wins on thanksgiving and i think i
know the answer to this one before it's
even typed in
third most wins on thanksgiving wow okay
uh i'll go
i don't know this i'm gonna go the
washington football team ah it's the
bears i was that would be my other guest
yeah i was thinking the packers i was
thinking the packers but the same idea
because you would have played the lions
that's what i mean
i was thinking of the teams that are in
the division with the lions or the
cowboys and have been around for a long
time that's why i went with them but
okay
all right good go ahead get your first
pick out of the way all right i'm up and
there are plenty of good ones to choose
from
i'm going to start with lamar jackson
against the pittsburgh defense
especially since he is
undermanned in his running game it's
only his his
what what is it is it his third career
start against pittsburgh remember last
time yeah
he only had one start against pittsburgh
and it and it wasn't great even though
they won in overtime
with mason rudolph and and doc hodges
both playing in that game that the
ravens won in overtime
this is his second crack this season at
the steelers
they outplayed the steelers last time
around but lost to them
what lamar jackson does or doesn't do
against that pittsburgh defense is going
to go a long way toward determining
whether or not the ravens win because
they're not going to have jk dobbins
they're not going to have mark ingram
and who knows who else they may not have
between now and tomorrow night chris
no you're right it's a it's a big game
for the ravens there's
a lot of pressure on lamar jackson
definitely i mean we're they're under a
microscope in there in baltimore right
now
with the way they lost last week you
know the harbaugh raibl
thing the kovid 19 short week holy cow
so i have a hard time thinking lamar
jackson won't
he'll have to play phenomenal football
tomorrow night for them to beat the
steelers you know on the road on
thanksgiving night
all right i i mean i i don't usually do
this but
for the sake of this game i will i mean
because of mahomes versus brady
i gotta go there and i know they're not
on the field at the same time
but this might be the last time we see
them on the field together
uh at you know in a match-up in a
competitive football game like this
so that's big and of course with the
stories that are surrounding the bucks
right now
and you know just a roller coaster of
brady and the offense
um the chiefs being the kings and the
super bowl
everybody expects to be the super bowl
team again this year all of those things
i just thought i find this a fascinating
matchup and i look at you know kansas
city
again they're showing their versatility
on the offensive side of the ball
they can pressure the quarterback what's
that do to brady
and what kind of answers does todd
bowles have for mahomes and their deep
passing game
um i i think that's gonna be that to me
is probably the marquee game
of the weekend i'm very excited to watch
that yeah oh that one's gonna be great
and the buccaneers have a chance to get
back on the horse they have not fared
well in big spots this year
and if they lose that one they fall to
seven and five they get their bye week
after that
then they got a four game push to try to
get to the post season
i've got several to choose from here
the one that fascinates me the most the
story of the week
last week that we've forgotten about so
far this week taysom hill is the
quarterback of the saints well
we saw what the broncos did to tuatanga
viloa so
taysom hill versus vic fangio seasoned
veteran
grizzled defensive coach there's enough
film out there of taysom hill from the
past four years
that maybe fangio can figure out what to
do to confuse and we saw early in the
game last week
taysom hill took a drop held onto the
ball a little too long and got confused
i think with taysom hill you always got
to keep him on the move
i think decisions have to come quickly
and i think that if the defense
takes away that first thing he wants to
do on a given play
that could be enough to get him to
freeze and then maybe you can blow the
whole thing up but
whatever they did to tour adjust it
focus it
see if they can get taysom hill to fall
into the same trap where maybe he gets
benched
during the game we saw it happen last
week where tua comes out for ryan
fitzpatrick
who knows maybe if the broncos shut down
the saints offense we see some jameis
winston on sunday but that that's a
fascinating matchup to me can taste
he'll make it 2-0
against not one of the best defenses in
football but one of the best defensive
minds in football yeah that's right it's
fangio and his game plans are always
impressive he never gets like really
exposed or anything like that
defending taysom hill is a lot harder
than offending tua though
i'm sorry to say that that's where it's
going to be you know and of course the
saints offense in general
is better than miami too i was really
impressed with what i saw from taysom
hill yesterday watching that film back
you know again it wasn't perfect like
you said but damn
you know made some unbelievable throws
had some throws that were in normal
rhythm drop back and you went oh that
looks good
you know really only had one dicey
careless decision down there that a
interception dropped around the the goal
line
but you know that threat of their
running game because it can be dominant
and then the threat now of him being
able to
run be also behind that run game it it
makes him tough
it really does and i like their little
play action let receivers get down the
field and he can run if he's got to and
make it simple so
i'm with you but i'm expecting the
saints win there all the way all right
my next one
i'll go to derek henry versus the colts
run seven
hey it's it's we know tennessee
is going through derrick henry not that
it's got to be a hundred yards every
week
but anytime they start to get to 80 or
90
it's then you go to it's been effective
enough it's been effective enough to now
where the play action pass to aj brown
and corey davis is going to be
even more effective and gash you that
way the colts are one of those defenses
where
they might be able to go oh yeah no
you've only you've run it 23 times and
you only got 62 yards
that could be a very real thing uh and
that to me this is not about 100 yard
game it's more about
does he get to around that 90 number
then i'd go ooh
the titans are doing okay and they're
going to probably win the game but if
he's down in the 70s high
60s something like that i'd go they're
in trouble and the colts are probably
going to win the football game
i'll be excited to see that yeah that's
another great game this weekend the
titans very anxious to get another crack
at the colts because the titans were up
17
13 a couple of special teams miscues
next thing you know it's 27
17 indianapolis when i get ready for
this segment
i look at the full slate of games and i
just wait for things to emerge yeah some
of the games you look at and you say
there's really nothing there when i saw
raiders at falcons it's like there's
there's really nothing here and then i
remembered
i remembered john gruden
got fired in what essentially was a
palace coup
they went to raheem morris and made sure
he wanted the job
before they fired john gruden now for
the first time
it's gruden versus raheem morris and you
know
damn well that john gruden is going to
remember it
he's going to be motivated by it and
he's going to try to hang 50
on the falcons if he can because of it
so
you know we haven't had any snide
comments yet maybe we'll have him after
the game
but this gruden versus raheem thing is
going to have some potential heat
because i think gruden's probably still
pissed off that he feels like he got
stabbed in the back by a guy who was on
his staff well yeah and i
listen i know raheem there's no way he
stabbed anybody in the back that's just
not what he did
they came to him they came to him well
because they know what i'm saying you
know i know what you're saying you're
right i
made sure he's going to take the job bro
i think they knew they were going to
have a tough conversation with john and
that if it went the wrong
way that they might have to let him go
and that's why they kind of had to do
that but either way
you're right and john's going to say
things to his team and get them
motivated to go
he'll convince himself that he will
he'll convince himself against that guy
stole my job freaking guys
you know yes he will that's what that's
what competitors do i have a pick left
right
bakittar bhaktiari i can never say his
name
first khalil mack because i just think
that not only that match up but
the pass protection for aaron rodgers
you know i don't expect them to be able
to run the ball
if that front four can get to rogers
chicago can make that game interesting
if bakatiyari and that offensive line
can handle the front four without extra
help in doing things like that then
green bay will run away with it but i
think a lot of pressure on mack in that
front to disrupt that game in rogers
extra syllable in bhaktivedanta
and two of the highest paid players at
their positions bhaktiari with the
contract that he signed a couple of
weeks ago
makes him the highest paid offense i
played with his brother what's worse is
that i can't say his damn name i mean i
played with his brother that's how the
adult i am sometimes geez
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports